the way we walk can tell us just as much
about our health as our pulse or blood
pressure
professor kitab youth group and MIT
csail can now measure a person's locking
speeds continuously and not intrusively
with a device called wide gate by
sending low radiation wireless signals
that reflect off of a person's body and
back to the device
why gate can measure different people's
walking speeds with 95 to 99 percent
accuracy
why gate could help detect injuries or
health issues like cognitive decline or
cardiac disease and does so while
anonymizing your data as nothing more
than a dot on the screen why gate first
distinguishes walking from other
movements like reading or cleaning and
then use this special signal processing
algorithms to distinguish between
different walking speeds why gate is
also 85 to 99% accurate at measuring a
person's stride length which could allow
researchers to better understand
conditions like Parkinson's disease that
are characterized by reduced to step
size in the future the researchers hope
to test the system on people's
disabilities like Parkinson's multiple
sclerosis or Alzheimer's
[Music]
you